But I saw you speaking to this with uh
Sheikh Uthman ibn Farooq in the street.
>> Yes.
>> But didn't he didn't he clarify that
more than one person can be called the
Messiah and
>> There you go. That's what I was saying.
He lied and got caught. Well, this is
why he get This is how he earned the
name Uthman ibn footnote.
The question that I'm asking is what is
the purpose of the Messiah? Why is he
identified as the Messiah? Because the
Messiah has a specific meaning for a
specific role. My question to you guys
as Muslims, why is he identified as the
Messiah? What is he anointed to do?
Is it not that he just had like his
message like to like you know the Quran
calls him like a messenger. So, Muhammad
was a messenger. Moses was a messenger.
Yeah, so you're saying what what makes
him specific like as an individual
>> specifically the Messiah? I thought you
I I saw a video on your channel I
haven't you know I haven't been on here
in a minute. So, I went to your channel,
but I saw you speaking to this with uh
Sheikh Uthman ibn Farooq in the street.
Yes. But didn't he didn't he clarify
that more than one person can be called
the Messiah and
>> There you go. That's what I was saying.
No, he lied. He lied and got caught.
Well, this is why he get This is how he
earned the name Uthman ibn footnote.
Because he said he he said he was going
to bring a hadith stating that yes,
multiple prophets are identified as uh
Messiahs in Islam. But what he did was
instead of bringing a hadith, he brought
a footnote that had it even in the
footnote it had a a textual error in it.
To where it looked like it was saying
Messiahs, but it wasn't. It was um it
was something else. Why?
>> I have a question though. You know the
You know the Quran doesn't uh
make it to Well, we don't raise Jesus
Christ
up as God. So, even if he's called the
Messiah like he has some important I'm
not sure why
why you would be like attacking that
point to begin with. We were We already
believe he's top five prophets to begin
with. Like what are you What are you
trying to suggest?
>> Let's Let's here for a second. You said
that we as Muslims do not raise Jesus on
this pedestal to be God, but we still
recognize him as the Messiah. This is
the point of the title of the room. Join
Islam, lose Jesus. Because the Messiah,
according to scripture, is God.
>> No,
but that would be that would be from
your your perspective, from your
scripture. That's Here's the point. This
is This is why I started off with What
does Messiah mean? Where do you get it
from? Because where you get it from is
not Islamic sources. You get it from us.
You get it from the our scriptures.
>> Well, of course we say it's revelation.
From our
According to the According to the
revelation, the Messiah is divine. Wait,
wait, what Old Testament?
It's fine. Let me
It's fine. It's fine. I'm saying
Yeah, yeah, according to like biblical
scriptures, that the the Messiah is
divine. Well, of course that's what the
what You know that we believe the Quran
is a clarification. So, it's just It's
just a clarifying that Jesus Christ was
not God, and makes a separation between
men and God. Okay. Yeah. So, this this
is what I'm saying. Number one, the
Quran doesn't say that it's a
clarification of the previous
scriptures. It does. No, it doesn't.
Or not in those specific words. It says
it's a criterion over Not in those
supreme authority. No, it doesn't. I've
seen you It does. It does. It does.
Chill on him, chill on him.
I I seen you speak to it
with Abbas.
Yeah. You kind of got angry at him. You
like you're insulting our intelligence
and saying this is that and the third.
But it does say in Surah 5, verse 48, I
see you go through all the time. And
also Surah 5, verse 68, how the Jews and
the Christians they have nothing to
stand on until they observe all
scriptures. Yeah. And then in Surah 5,
verse Yeah, no, until they observe all
the Quran, the Torah, and the Gospels.
It doesn't say the Quran. Let's let's
let's open it up. Surah 5, verse 68, we
can Yeah, the Quran first in the Quran
is the Furqan, which is literally the
word for criteria. That distinguishes
two things.
>> Yeah, it it also mentions it also calls
the Torah the Furqan as well. Yeah, but
that was the original Torah that's with
us today. The
Torah that's with us today. That's the
real Torah he's talking about, the real
one given to Moses. Yeah, if we Where is
where You don't even know who the Quran
was or who the Torah was given to.
Moses.
Where does your Quran say that? I'll let
I'll let everybody else Everybody's
going to have an assignment. Bob, you
show me where the Quran I have the
assignment. Yeah. Bob, you tell me where
the Quran says that the Torah was given
to Moses. And you Aaron, you're going to
5:68. Yeah, I'm there right now. It says
>> All right, what does it say? It says
like say prophet, oh people of the book.
So he's speaking to all the people and
all people of the book. You have nothing
to stand on unless you observe the
Torah, the gospel, and what what has
been revealed to you from your Lord.
Where does it say Quran there?
That's That's obviously speaking about
the Quran. No.
Was not Was not the Psalms also revealed
to them? Bro, you know it's not talking
about the Psalms, bro. Come on.
>> Wait, why not? Bro, it's talking about
the the Quran obviously. This is
>> Good for commentary. You're saying
You're saying obvious, so this is what
we know from the Quran totality. Okay.
>> We know that the
Torah was revealed to the people of the
book. Okay.
>> The Psalms was revealed to the people of
the book. Okay.
>> And the gospel was revealed to the
people of the book. The Quran was not
revealed to the people of the book. It
was revealed to Muhammad. Okay, fine. It
says right after that, and your Lord's
revelation to you, oh prophet, will only
cause many of them to increase in
wickedness and disbelief. So do you
agree So don't grieve for the people who
disbelieve. The Quran makes a
distinction. It says
they have nothing to stand on unless
they observe the Torah, the gospel, and
all that has been revealed to them. To
them. And what has been revealed to you
from your Lord.
Speaking to the prophet Muhammad. Aaron,
read the verse again for me. Okay, say
oh prophet, oh people of the book. You
have nothing to stand on unless you
observe the Torah, the gospel, and what
has been revealed to you from your Lord.
>> talking to the people of the book. What
does it speak But then after that it
says, and your Lord's revelation to you,
oh prophet, will only cause many of them
to increase in wickedness and disbelief.
>> Yeah, so the next verse now he's talking
to Muhammad not the people of the book.
Okay, fine. Let's go let's go to 68. I
mean 48. Look. Okay. So that So that is
not talking about the Quran. I'm My
argument is that that's talking about
the Torah, the Zabur, the Psalms, the
Gospel, the writings of the prophets and
everything. Perhaps we have a different
take on that because
in the Quran it talks about how the Isa
bin Maryam was revealed the the Gospel.
And you know that the the Torah was
revealed to Moses. It doesn't say that.
It doesn't say the Torah was revealed to
Moses but it does say Jesus is
confirming the Torah that came before.
>> Okay, fine. We'll go with that. Yeah,
let's go to 5:48. But it says and you
I've seen you go through this many of
times with Abbas and and other people as
well.
>> Yeah, bro. I'm a I'm a I'm a hafiz a
hafiz on these on these Hafiz. Yeah,
okay. Yeah.
What do you what do you make of this? We
have revealed to you O prophet this book
with the truth as a confirmation of
previous scriptures and a supreme
authority on them. That's a terrible
translation of it. That's my take. The
word is not supreme authority, it's
guardian, Muhaimin. Okay. Or what do you
make of that then? If the if if let's
let's take the word guardian. If the
Quran is a guardian, let's say over past
scriptures, how how would it like what
do you make of that? It's a guardian. It
protects It protects the scriptures from
the lies of the Jews and Christians when
they lie about their scriptures. It
protects it from it and is a and is a
witness to the previous scriptures.
Okay, so for example, let's say we go to
the Bible and we see in the Bible that
let's say we see in the Bible that Jesus
Christ will have authority on the day of
judgment and he will throw into hell
whoever he wills. And then we read the
Quran and we see in Ayat al-Kursi where
Allah says that no no one will have
intercession unless he wills. So we take
the Quran over the Bible.
Uh no because that shows
>> the from the Muslim perspective that
you're saying that's what we're saying.
>> Okay. Okay, from the Muslim perspective
>> Based off this verse though. Based off
this verse. Yeah, that's that's tough.
That's tough. I I
I don't know because according to the
verse it's not a it's not a guardian or
or it's not a criterion over or judge
over the previous scriptures. It guards
it from the lies of the people around.
That's fine. If you say it guards it
from, that's fine. It's the same thing.
>> Yeah. So, it's a guardian. It protects
from the lies around the that the people
speak when they just start with their
words and they lie about it. Then we're
saying the same thing then. No, what
you're saying is that is you're you're
taking it as a as a judge. Like if if
one is saying the other, what do what do
we what do I take? According to your
Quran, you're supposed to take my book.
That we take the Bible as authority. And
so
>> you why. Because because Muhammad, when
he was supposed to get confirmation of
his prophethood, who did Allah tell him
to go ask?
>> This is what he says, "If you are in
doubt about what we have revealed to
you." He says, "Go to the Now, but why?"
No, but cuz cuz it's supposed to
confirm. Yeah, it confirms what? So, for
example, these verses are speaking about
Moses and this that and the third.
>> Yeah, so he's Allah says, "Go to the
past scriptures and you'll see that
these same stories are in there."
Beautiful.
>> but not to say that okay, I'm going to
look at this and then confirm it this
way. No, that's what that's what that's
what you do, Harun. Harun.
>> Yeah. I'm not going to bring a book and
say my book confirms the Quran, even
though it came Where are we at? Uh 1,400
years later?
My book confirms the Quran.
Right? It it confirms what's in your
what's in the Quran. You're not going to
then go to the Quran,
check it and say, "Huh, this is
different. I got to go with the new one.
The Quran must be the one that's
corrupted and false."
No. You use the old to judge the new.
No, every Wait. But wait, Bob, 1 second.
Let me let me respond to you.
>> what Allah told Muhammad to do. No, but
bro, he obviously told him to go to the
past I don't even obviously. He says,
"If you are in doubt about what we have
revealed to you, oh prophet, then go to
the past scriptures and you'll see the
same exact stories." No, so hold on. So,
what does that mean?
>> If you're in doubt, like what you just
brought up, if I see if I see this in
the Quran and on the same subject I see
something else in the Bible, which one
do I take? When you're in doubt, where
are you supposed to go? No, no, no. Not
in doubt or listen, Allah says to the
Prophet Muhammad in the Quran. The face
you make is kind of funny. Allah says to
the Prophet Muhammad in the Quran, don't
follow their desires, follow the truth
of what has come to you. So, never did
Allah
order the Prophet Muhammad to go to the
Bible and be like, okay, take this over
what over the Quran. He says He says to
him specifically over and over and over,
don't follow don't follow the truth.
If Allah is giving him revelation, Okay.
he doesn't need anything else, right? If
Allah is giving him revelation and his
>> need nothing. and his heart is in doubt
about it, Then what should he do? then
go to the past scriptures and you'll see
that the same story is there. Okay,
fine. So, that's how to verify if his
revelations is true. Is that by going to
the past scriptures to see that?
>> For his heart. He's a human being. For
his heart.
>> No problem, but listen. The Here's what
Allah is saying. Allah is saying, if you
doubt,
go ask the people who read the scripture
before you. The proof is there. That'll
verify your revelations that I'm giving
you. And if he
No,
no, let him talk. Let him talk. Let him
go ahead, Avery. So, if he doubts, he
can get his verification from the
previous scripture. About the It's like,
Muhammad, if you're in doubt, go to the
previous scripture and
>> Okay, so does does that mean that he
should follow it?
Absolutely. No, what does Allah say? I
just told you, what does he say inside
the Quran to the Prophet Muhammad? He
tells him
>> in doubt, go ask What's up, Rob? Avery,
what's up? Avery, what's up? I just
brought you. I told you. He says, don't
follow what has been revealed to the or
he says, follow the truth of what has
been revealed to you. This is what Allah
says inside the Quran. He says, don't
follow their desires over the truth that
has which has come to you. This is what
Allah says to the Prophet Muhammad in
the Quran. Their desires, right? No, but
he says, follow the truth. It says over
and over and how Over their vain
desires, right? No, this this is another
verse. This is speaking to
>> talking about 48. No, in Surah 5, verse
48.
>> Yes, you're talking about 48. No, I I
No,
yeah, yeah.
48, it says
for them for him to not follow their
vain desires. Obviously, it's talking
about the people of the book who who go
away from Allah's teachings. And they
try to trick him and stuff like that
like they were trying to do in verse 43.
Bro, are are you really making the claim
and saying that the Prophet Muhammad
was ordered to follow the Bible?
Absolutely. He was supposed to use that.
That was his
Can I get in Can I get in The Bible
Arun, the Bible was supposed to be used
as Muhammad's proof text. No, but we I
just told you Allah says to him
He even says inside the Quran that the
Jews and the Christians will never be
satisfied with you until you submit to
their scriptures. So he says, "But if
you do that, you will have no helper on
the day of judgement." Wait, wait, wait.
>> Allah says Allah says this inside the
Quran. It doesn't say submit to their
scriptures. He says the Jews and
Christians will never be satisfied with
you until you follow their faith. Until
you follow them. Until you follow them.
>> their Yes, until you follow
Specifically, hold on. Cuz specifically,
it's talking about the disbelievers
among them, the hypocrites. Not the true
believers among them, the scriptures and
the ones who truly follow. The ones who
truly follow their books, Allah calls
them winners. Allah calls them true
believers. Okay, you're talking about
the verse of the Christians and the
Sabeans and the Jews and the the
>> Not just that one. Not just that one. It
talks about how among the Jews are true
believers who follow their scriptures.
And among the Christians, there's a
party of them who truly follow their
scriptures and stuff like that. Calls
them true believers. At the same time,
the Quran doesn't
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, yeah, bro, what are you speaking
towards? I mean, bro, if if your claim
is that the Prophet Muhammad was ordered
to follow the Bible and to follow the
Torah, bro, how how
how that is that is such a
a far-fetched,
wild claim to make? Why?
Because he Allah literally says inside
the Quran that they will not be
satisfied with you, the Christians and
the Jews, until you follow their faith.
Until you follow their faith.
>> Which cuz you you you're messing up the
scripture again. Okay, let's let's bring
the verses out.
>> Which First of all, you need to identify
which Jews and Christians he's talking
about. It's not
It's not It's not a which Jews and What
is he doing? Allah says
>> So why is it that Allah at some points
talks about a party of the Jews and the
party of the Christians? Does Allah say
that? If all of them are just bunched
together.
>> Okay, I'll bring I'll bring another
verse. Allah says inside the Quran that
he did he he is the one who has revealed
the scripture or has revealed this
religion of truth which will prevail
over others.
And Allah says inside the Quran that no
that no
religion is acceptable in his eyes
except for the religion of Islam. So
Islam will prevail over the other
religions. This is what Allah says
inside the Quran.
>> Wait a second. Aren't Aren't not Jews
and Aren't not Jews and Christians
identified as Muslims in in the in the
scripture? Okay, if you're speaking on
>> It's all the one It's all one religion.
Well, if if you're speaking on the term
Muslim in the sense that
they only believe inside the the the the
Christians by the scripture and the
Jewish scripture, then no. Because Allah
calls you guys fasiqoon. The He calls
you like disbelievers because if Why
he's This is clarified inside the Quran.
>> Which ones does he call disbelievers?
The ones that believe in the Trinity.
The ones Yeah,
no and the ones who don't believe in in
the the Quran and which has which has
been
>> There you go. So there's specific Jews
and Christians that he calls
disbelievers. No, so these are not But
there's other Jews and Christians
believers. These are not Muslims. They
are Muslims according to the Quran.
Okay.
>> They submit to the will of Allah. Yeah,
okay. Muslims in the sense that they
submit their will to one God. Okay, but
Muslims
>> And they answer to the scriptures that
Allah revealed.
>> But the religion of Islam You have to To
be upon the religion of Islam, you have
to what? Believe in the Quran, believe
in the Gospel, and believe in the Torah.
You don't You don't accept the You Even
if you would believe in one God, say if
you rejected the Trinity, one day you
woke up Avery woke up, opened his eyes.
Okay, yeah. Okay, what You believe in
the one and three. If you If you say you
said you rejected the one and three, and
you only believed in a one and only.
Still, if you don't believe inside the
Quran, you would still have a problem.
Cuz you would still be according to the
from the Islamic lens a disbeliever,
right? Why? Because you disbelieve
inside what has been revealed to you of
truth. The
But I think I think I know the problem
here.
I'm
I Bro, I'm not just disagreeing with
what you just said. Okay.
>> What I'm saying is is that those
particular Jews and Christians that
rejected the Quran and Muhammad's
prophethood are identified as
disbelievers because they don't believe
in all of Allah's revelation. They're
only taking their own in part while
rejecting the last revelation. They're
supposed to believe in all of them. Just
like the Muslims are supposed to believe
in all of them. The Jews supposed to
believe in all of them. When the Jews
rejected Jesus,
the party of them that rejected them
identified as losers and disbelievers.
The Christians and the Jews that reject
Muhammad are identified as losers and
disbelievers. But the ones who accept
him are identified as believers. Yeah,
and just to add onto this, even if you
believe in one God, you don't believe in
a Trinity, right? You don't believe in a
tri-personal God. Or you're just a Jew
like you were talking about, that people
like these Christians that don't believe
in the Trinity are essentially
Unitarians. If they reject the
prophethood and authority of Muhammad,
they're identified as kafirs in the
Quran. So, you have to both believe in
one God and accept Muhammad's revelation
and his authority as a prophet.
>> [snorts]